all right this is from the daily wire
last week um high schoolers in a
wisconsin town not far from madison had
to endure a sing a song and dance
routine by a french teacher
from their school who was dressed in
drag
shannon valladolid the
district's director of information
public relations reportedly admitted
that staff performances are vetted by
the high school's teaching faculty
french teacher matthew cashton whose
linkedin page states he is looking to
shift away from k-12 public education
into higher education to study abroad in
programming and advising
perform for the students during
middleton high school's fine arts week
empower wisconsin reported quote cashton
strutted on to the auditorium stage in a
high-cut
blue sequined dress red boots and a
blonde wig lip-syncing and dancing to
rain on me by pop divas lady gaga and
ariana grande
it was all a surprise to the assembled
students who apparently had no idea
they're about to get a drag show from
one of their teachers
and we have footage of that let's play
just a little bit of that footage
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so
it's just a male teacher
in drag strutting around in front of his
uh minor students
no problem there at all
and this is how i mean just
think about how
like the
aside from the the perversion the
degeneracy involved here just the
the gold the the gall and the bulk can
we turn this off just turn it off i
can't look at it anymore
the gall and the gumption
to do this
to do it at all but especially to do it
right now
when everybody's talking about grooming
in the public schools
and and for once there's actually kind
of some national focus on that issue
and the left is busy saying oh it's not
happening at all and then you decide to
do a drag performance
that you it's apparently vetted by the
administration
they saw this plan and said oh yeah
sounds good let's do that
obviously knowing that this video is
going to end up online it's not it's not
going to be a secret nothing is
especially not that
but they don't speaking of not caring
they just don't care
from the school system their attitude is
hey these are these are our kids not
yours you can complain about it all you
want
what are you going to do pull your kids
out and homeschool them
we know most of you probably won't so
complain all you want
that's their attitude a middleton cross
plains area schools parent alerted radio
host vicki mckenna in an email about
this writing quote i send my children to
school and entrust them to
teachers that i have to believe are
professionals who won't destroy their
innocence for their own pleasure if
matthew cashton makes the decision to
perform his drag show at school what
else does he do in the classroom with a
room full of children what kind of
educators thought this was appropriate
drag shows are fine arts if a teacher is
a pole dancer or stripper can they also
perform for my children i don't care
what matthew cashton does us out of
school i do care what he does at
middleton high school
and that is a very good question as well
if he's doing this on camera on stage
what does he do like if he's willing to
do that on stage
with everybody watching and when he must
know that there's probably with people
with their phones out
what is he doing in the classroom when
when he's not on stage
now when he's pretty confident that he's
not being filmed
[Music]
this is uh yeah
grooming in the public school system
definitely
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated